whatever happens at the summit here in
Singapore it will have major
ramifications for the rest of the world
in general and for the Asian Pacific
region in particular with that story
tonight from Seoul South Korea here
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Greg palca no one's looking closer to
what's happening at the Singapore Trump
Kim's Summit than those on the Korean
Peninsula and region they've been most
directly affected by tensions that have
sent the area to the brink of nuclear
war South Koreans have been living in
the shadow of the North's military
threat for years bustling Seoul is just
35 miles from the tents porter reason
why South Korean president moon jae-in
took the diplomatic lead with two
summits with Kim the locals however have
been through peace moves before it's not
a sense of delusional hope here but
there is cautious optimism that we're
seeing some really big positive
developments Singapore means a lot to
neighbor Japan as well it wants to make
sure long and medium-range missiles
which could target Tokyo are discussed
also mentioned at last week's White
House summit with President Trump
Japanese Prime Minister Abe is concerned
about humanitarian issues especially
Japanese citizens who have been
kidnapped by North Korea I have
explained the abduction issue again and
conveyed to him with the earnest wish of
the families of the abductees both
countries interests will be taken into
account in Singapore according to
Secretary of State Pompeo there is no
daylight between the South Koreans the
Japanese in the United States with
respect to our approach to how we
resolve this issue with respect to North
Korea as for North Korean citizens they
reportedly don't even know when or where
the summit is happening just that their
leader will be meeting with President
Trump and I'll say he cares less about
them more about getting respect having
high-level meetings they can build a
narrative around that
and portray the leader as an equal to
the president United States all sides
are looking also and whether there at
least could be some movement at this
meeting towards the declaring of an end
to the Korean War that conflict was
halted with the true some 65 years ago
that indeed would be a peace dividend
from the Singapore summit rig palca live
in Seoul one hour later Greg thanks